los tres partidos que formarán el
próximo gobierno alemán los
socialdemócratas los verdes y los
liberales firmaron este martes aquí en
berlín su acuerdo de coalición el
contrato de 177 páginas con todos sus
objetivos para los próximos cuatro años
con esto se cumple el último requisito
para que olaf scholz se convierta en el
noveno canciller alemán de la postguerra
en el sucesor de angela merkel
olaf scholz estará acompañado por un
gabinete con equidad de género ocho
hombres y ocho mujeres y en lo que está
siendo descrito como un momento
importante para alemania todos los
ministerios encargados de la diplomacia
y de la seguridad estarán bajo el mando
de mujeres
el miércoles en una ceremonia en el boom
de estar en el parlamento alemán olaf
scholz tomará juramento como nuevo
canciller también se reunirá con el
presidente alemán el jefe de estado
walter steinmeier y con angela merkel y
asumirá así sus funciones como el nuevo
líder del gobierno alemán
scholz ya dio a entender que su primer
viaje al exterior será a parís para
reunirse con el presidente francés
emmanuel manco